ce match devait être une fête pour tous
les animaux mais ce 32e de finale de la
coupe de france de football féminin
entre montigny et le psg se transforme
en calvaire
suite aux fortes chutes de neige les
terrains de football yvelinois sont
impraticables et le stade de la couldre
nisha pas programmé à l'origine ce
dimanche 27 janvier à 14h30
la rencontre est d'abord reporté par la
fédération française de football au
mercredi 30 à 14h30 aussi puis
finalement à 20 heures la déception est
alimentaire est grandement au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est une fête parce que
mettre un match à 14h30 c'est aberrant
pour les filles parce que les filles
travaillent on n'est pas des pro a et
sont prêts à le travail et termine à 18
ans voire 19 heures le soir on va
composer parce que là haut j'ai pas de
terrain le terrain sont fermés on voit
un s'entraîner en salle on va aller
faire des footings et ont essayé de
trouver une solution
j'ai une semaine pour trouver une
solution est trouvée défi apte à jouer
mercredi prochain les tribunes du
terrain d'honneur du stade de la couldre
resteront vides
la rencontre va devoir se jouer sur le
terrain synthétique du club
seule surface jouable du côté unis
montrent un on crie au favoritisme
les dates de report proposé par le club
saint quentinois le 3 et le 10 février
ne convenait pas au paris saint germain
je trouve que ce sont des
internationales et que l'international a
présenté l'équipe comprend donc
voilà ces dates là donc les filles de
jean dany grosser ont en tout cas une
motivation de plus pour renverser l'ogre
parisien mercredi soir lors de ce choc
classée à risques